aber wir haben ja mit einem gravierenden
Problem zu tun und endlich wird es
angesprochen und ich frage mich auch
wenn ich hier zuhöre was haben wie tief
haben wir eigentlich alle auch ein
bisschen Selbstkritik in den letzten
Jahren geschlafen mich treibt ja
wirklich um dass wir bei jedem fast
jedem Sachverhalt den wir in den letzten
Wochen sehen sehen wir ein und dasselbe
Phänomen Deutschland ist sozusagen
eingerostet ein eingerostetes Land eine
rostrepublik was meine ich damit wir
sind jahrzehntelang im Sonnenschein
gesurft da gab es ein bisschen
ozonenloch da gab es ein bisschen
Waldsterben da waren irgendwelche
Auseinandersetzungen auf anderen
Erdteilen das hat unser Leben doch
eigentlich nicht maßgeblich beeinflusst
und das sind wir irgendwie eingerostet
denn jetzt seit 2015 Stichwort Migration
dann jetzt Pandemie
unvorstellbar gewesen jetzt ist sie da
dann Flut und immer immer stellen wir
fest dass wir nicht vorbereitet sind
dass uns wird nicht vorhersehbares so
überwältigt das weder unsere Behörden
noch unsere Administration noch unser
moralischer Kompass dass man selber
Verantwortung übernehmen muss dass man
nicht einfach eine E-Mail schreiben kann
in ein Flutgebiet und dann nach Hause
gehen das vielleicht der Chef des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes oder anderer
mal den Innenminister anruft und sagt da
kommt eine riesige Flut ich habe das
gesehen auf den Bildern sowas habe ich
noch nie gesehen nein wir haben eine
E-Mail geschickt habt ihr nicht gelesen
schade jetzt Leute tot oder bei der bei
der Pandemie unser
Beispiel dass ich dieses dreiste Virus
auch am Wochenende verbreitet wo wir
doch unsere Gesundheitsämter zu sind ja
wir waren ein Jahr nicht in der Lage die
Faxe da irgendwie in den Griff zu
kriegen jetzt sehen wir bei diesen
bka-zahlen das ist neue Deliktsgruppen
gibt die sich über Jahre aufbauen und
niemand schlägt Alarm ja das wird schon
vorbei gehen so wie das ozonenloch oder
andere Sachen irgendwie vielleicht
vorbeigegangen sind wir sind irgendwie
wir verharren in einem unzureichenden
Zustand und jedes neue Ereignis führt
uns das vor Augen und jetzt kommt doch
die große Frage was folgern wir daraus
ich will mal was machen was eigentlich
brisant ist und man eigentlich nicht
macht was ist eigentlich wenn
Deutschland angegriffen wird oh das ist
unvorstellbar ach so das genauso
unvorstellbar wie die Pandemie vor zwei
Jahren unvorstellbar war es ist genauso
unvorstellbar wie das eine Flut als
ganze Dörfer auslöscht und den Schutt
legt genauso unvorstellbar es ist
übrigens genauso unvorstellbar wie das
hunderttausende Millionen Leute zu uns
wollen unvorstellbar so unvorstellbar
ist es jetzt ob Deutschland in einem
Verteidigungsfall kommt und wie ist
unser Armee die Bundeswehr ausgerüstet
das ist die Metapher für alles kein
Panzer fährt kein Flieger fliegt zum
Glück müssen wir nicht mehr in
Afghanistan sein damit es alles nicht
auffällt wir sind auch da wieder nicht
vorbereitet und ich erwarte mir von
einer Politik ich kann es noch konkreter
machen von der nächsten Bundesregierung
dass sie uns verdammt noch mal auf die
Fälle vorbereitet die passieren können
denn jetzt haben wir sie erlebt und da
sehe ich eine große Verantwortung und
gleichzeitig aber auch eine große
verzeiht mir eine große lahmarschigkeit
sich an der Stelle ehrlich zu machen da
wird ein Ausschuss gegründeten
Arbeitsgruppe dann ist die Legislatur
vorbei dann kommen die neuen der neue
Minister muss ich erst anarbeiten der
neue Amtsleiter wird ausgetauscht da war
eine Flasche jetzt haben wir einen neuen
der ist auch eine Flasche also es ist
sozusagen es ist sozusagen irre und
jetzt kommt das was mich dabei am
meisten emotionalisiert ich glaube im
Grunde haben wir in unseren Verwaltungen
in unserer Politik in unseren Ämtern in
unseren Schulen in unseren
Sozialverbänden gute engagierte Leute
aber wir haben irgendwie ein
mehltau-system Mehltau ah so ein Mikado
Ding wer sich zuerst bewegt geht
natürlich auch das Risiko ein dass
sozusagen schief läuft der von mir
skizzierte der den Innenminister anruft
und sagt da kommt die größte Flutwelle
sie müssen handeln der sieht natürlich
hinterher aus wie ein Idiot wenn es nur
bisschen regnet und das nimmt
offensichtlich die Kraft von den
Menschen ihre bürgerliche Verantwortung
den Ämtern wahrzunehmen man ist ja nicht
Amtsträger sondern Bürger und als Bürger
handelt man verantwortungsvoll und
vorausschauend und mit Herz man sagt
nicht oh die Gruppen Vergewaltigungen
10% plus sondern man sagt es waren
wieder 30 Frauen die das erdulden
mussten ertragen mussten wie können wir
das verhindern da hat jeder
Verantwortung und ich glaube dass das
das macht mich so von Woche zu Woche
richtig richtig verrückt dass jeder neue
Fall uns das vor Augen führt und wir
wirklich gucken müssen dass wir uns da
nicht fügen es dulden sondern dass wir
jetzt sozusagen aus dem Quark kommen und
das ändern wir sind Bild und wir liefern
dir deine News auf Youtube zum nächsten
Video kommst Du hier und vergiss bitte
nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren